احلم ان انجب طفلا يسالني امي ما معنى
الحرب كلمات الكاتبه والشاعره الشهيره
الامريكيه ابلين ميريام لا يبدو انها
ستكون واقعا في المستقبل القريب فحرب
روسيا واوكرانيا التي دخلت عامها الثاني
جعلت كل الناس بمختلف اعمارهم يعرفون معنى
الحرب حتى وان لم تكن راحه تدور على ارض
بلادهم الكل تاثر الحرب غيرت العالم لكن
بقي ثابت وحيد مشاهد الدمار والقتل اكثر
من 21 الف مدني قتلوا وهذا رسميا بينما
التقديرات تشير لنحو مئه الف القتلى
والجرحى من جنود الطرفين يقدرون بنحو 300
الف هذا هو معنى الحرب لكن هل العام
الثاني قد يسعى فيه الجانبان لما هو اهم
من الطلقات الكلمات
السعي الى السلام يحدث عندما يتم استنفاده
جميع اشكال العدوان امر لا يلوح في الافق
الان تركيا التي كانت الوسيطه الابرز خلال
العام الماضي قد تتاثر وسطتها بسبب كارثه
الزلزال التي ضربتها والانتخابات المقبله
عليها وهنا
ظهر لاعب اخر الصين بخطتها المؤلفه هي
عشره نقطه رحبت بها روسيا طبعا بينما شككت
بها اوكرانيا وحلفائها بناء على تاريخ
تعاون موسكو وبكين ومع رفض الاخيره وصف ما
قامت به روسيا بالغزو لكن تبقى املا ولو
كان بسيطا المانيا وفرنسا طلبت الرئيس
الاوكراني زلينسكي بالتفكير جديا في
مفاوضات السلام وهو الذي اعلن انه لا يريد
لقاء بوتين مساعدات الغرب يبدو انها جعلت
زيلينسكي يطمع في المزيد من الانتصارات
على روسيا اعلن استعداد السيطره العسكريه
على القرم بينما حذره المسؤولون الالمان
والفرنسيون
تكون قادرين على ذلك اذا ماده الصين يدها
من اجل السلام تسعى لانهاء الحرب وهي التي
قد تاخذ حربا مشابهه في تايوان وتتوجه
مقاتلاتها بشكل خطر ومتزايد مع مقاتلات
امريكيه مثل ما حدث يوم امس فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي لكن باليد الاخرى قد تشعل الصراع
اكثر تعتزم بكين بدا انتاج مسيرات هجوميه
للجيش الروسي تمهيدا للاستخدام في
اوكرانيا شركه تصنيع المسيرات الصينيه
بينجو
تكنولوجي جاهزه لانتاج 100 طائره بدون
طيار من نوع زيت 180 وهذا ما تؤكده
المصادر الاستخباراتيه في الولايات
المتحده واكدته مصادر المانيه ايضا وفقا
لصحيفه درش بيجل المسيره الصينيه تشبه
مسيرات شاهد 136 الايرانيه والتي تستخدمها
روسيا والتي بريطانيا اليوم ان مخزونها
ينفذ لدى موسكو شركه صينيه اخرى يسيطر
عليها الجيش خططت لامر اخر وهواه امداد
روسيا بقطع بقطع غيار لطائراتها المقاتله
وتحديدا
تصدر معدات للاستخدام المدني ان صحت هذه
التقارير ودخلت الصين كلاعب الجديد قد
يتعقد الصراع بالطبع مع استمرار الدعم
العسكري الغربي الكبير لاوكرانيا المزيد
من الاسلحه يعني سعاد اقل والمزيد من
المناطق يعني المزيد من البؤس كلمه الزعيم
الهندي غاندي طبعا الصين نفت كل هذه
التقارير بينما الولايات المتحده وبشكل
رسمي لديها رايان واحد من بلينكن يؤكد
واخر من بايدن ينفي
شن